colossal stars Anne Hathaway and it's
the story of a girl who's struggling
with severe dependency on alcohol she is
full-blown alcoholic so much so that her
boyfriend played by Dan Stephen says get
out I can't deal with this anymore and
she moves back to her hometown she gets
a job working for Jason Sudeikis at his
bar and there's a monster raging through
South Korea and there might be a
connection and I'm not going to tell you
about that because I went into this
movie knowing nothing about it which was
so refreshing to see these story
elements drop in the film to be like
genuinely surprised by it and be
actually invested in a story not knowing
where it's going to go because this film
truly is original and different and I
don't want to tell you why but there's
definitely a sci-fi fantasy element and
it does involve a monster rampaging
through a city beyond that the film is
also a story about a girl who is trying
to come to terms with alcoholism and
trying to clean up her life and that's
where the film struggles because the
monster element of this movie I thought
was just so friggin cool and really
different and I just I loved seeing a
movie that had a twist to it that just
I've never seen before it's the more
standard aspects of this story that
we've seen many times in films that
didn't really feel as strong as the
fantasy element and it's a very ballsy
thing it's ambitious to try to combine
these to have your basic film about some
girl who's trying to clean up her life
and come to terms with what she's done
in the past and then she's meeting a new
friend that she hasn't seen since
elementary school in Jason Sudeikis is
character which becomes very important
because these two characters are
suddenly highly at odds with each other
and I say suddenly because that's
exactly how it feels in one scene
Sudeikis will be this sweet loving guy
and you're like man I could just go play
basketball with him or whatever and then
all of a sudden the next day he is legit
serial killer horrifying and I have no
idea exactly what's going on in this
character his mind I felt like I had
gotten up to go to the bathroom in the
middle of the movie and missed a crucial
scene where this character makes a
choice to change everything about him
but I never got up I watched the whole
movie from one scene to another this
character has so drastically changed
and it's very important to the film and
that's easily the biggest issue that I
can walk away from having with this
movie and Hathaway is really good in
this movie she gives a lot of nuance to
her performance there's a lot of
subtleties that she adds with the
humorous aspect of the film but also
with the drama but I just don't buy her
as an alcoholic that aspect of her
character not really selling it for me
she's always gorgeous and beautiful even
when she's completely hungover like out
of her mind hungover she's missing time
she's forgetting things she's saying she
still looks amazing and I just I didn't
buy her as an alcoholic and that was
something that was really important to
the story she kind of goes the route of
like that college girl like oh my god
I'm so drunk like I can't just just go
away I'll think about stuff later like
oh my god like I'm like really I don't
know so the fantasy aspects of this
movie I thought were so unique and
especially the ending I really liked the
way they went about doing it and even
the last shot is it's really great but
it's the more standard elements of this
film that I thought had a serious
clashing of tone because it would go
from really funny and light-hearted to
suddenly really serious where thousands
of people quite literally are dying and
it was like okay these tones just don't
really match up but still the fact that
there is an original and different movie
out in theaters now that does have good
performances despite the fact that the
story is uneven at times I would
recommend seeing colossal and I'm going
to give it a beat guys thank you so much
as always for watching stay tuned this
weekend I'm going to be releasing my
review for alien vs. predator now I did
film my AVP 1 and 2 reviews when I still
had braces so no I didn't magically get
braces again they were just pre filmed
guys you are the best thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]